krishna ayuda a su padre en un puesto
del mercado central de la Vega la vega
Es el lugar que visitan en la actualidad
muchos santiaguinos para esquivar Los
Altos precios de los alimentos como
consecuencia de la inflación anualizada
del más de 12%. hace más de tres décadas
que los chilenos no experimentaban Un
aumento tan alto en los alimentos en lo
que es la fruta la verdura se ha subido
mucho Ya que en las plantaciones el
abono está caro todo está caro en
realidad todo ya va subiendo Clara es
una pensionada y vino al mercado
buscando precios bajos evalúa muy bien
lo que va a comprar los pocos más de 200
dólares mensuales que recibe por
jubilación de media a los chilenos No
son suficientes para cubrir las
necesidades básicas y Clara debe medir
bien cómo gasta sus ingresos con una
precaución increíble Porque nada alcanza
estado horriblemente Caro se compra lo
justo y necesario
pero también tratando de no perder la
calidad de las cosas por eso se viene a
la vega que es más barato
Este es mi refrigerador
últimos días del mes la situación de Ana
quien gana sueldo mínimo y ha debido
Buscar un segundo trabajo no es muy
diferente su novela luce casi vacía y se
angustia porque cada vez compra menos
Colón que gana y no es suficiente para
alimentar a su familia el sueldo no da
para nada más que para medio vivir O sea
la quincena el sueldo se acabó hoy día
la alimentación también es mala para
nosotros los pobres porque nos vemos
obligados a comer arroz y fideo aunque
en el mes de febrero la inflación de un
pequeño respiro en Chile por primera vez
en 27 meses los chilenos siguen
preocupados por los precios altos
mejorar la economía se mantiene como uno
de los principales retos pendientes en
el segundo año de gobierno de boric que
apenas